>> Harlod: SOME IN THE MEDIA
SAYING THAT THE PRESS WAS TOO
QUICK TO DISMISS THE THEORY THAT
COVID COULD HAVE LEAKED FROM A
LAB.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
EGG ON THEIR FACE.
THIS WAS AN IDEA THAT WAS FIRST
PUT FORWARD BY MIKE POMPEO,
SECRETARY OF STATE,
DONALD TRUMP.
AND SOME THINGS MAY BE TRUE EVEN
IF DONALD TRUMP SAID THEM.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
THE POLITICAL LEFT IN THE MEDIA
MADE THIS MISTAKE AND SAID, IF
TOM COTTON IS SAYING SOMETHING,
IT CAN'T BE TRUE OR THEY ASSUMED
THAT.
AND THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> Harlod: ACCORDING TO A NEW
REPORT, BRITISH INTELLIGENCE NOW
THINKS THE LEAK FROM THAT LAB
COULD BE "FEASIBLE."
JESSE, I LIKE LOOKING AT GREG
WHEN I CALL YOU --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY WE
LOOK LIKE.
I KNOW, I GET IT.
AT LEAST YOU ARE NOT LOOKING AT
DAGEN AND THINKING MEAN.
>> Harlod: WHAT DO YOU THINK
WENT ON HERE?
>> Jesse: ARE YOU TALKING TO
ME?
I WILL TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED AND THIS IS THE MEDIA
ADMITTING THEY ARE BAD AT THEIR
JOBS.
HERE'S CHUCK TODD, HE SAID HE
GOT TANGLED UP IN POLITICS AND
COMPLETED WITH THE IDEA THAT THE
CHINESE DELIBERATELY RELEASED
IT.
WHO WAS THE ONE THAT TANGLED IT?
WHO WAS THE ONE THAT COMPLETED
IT?
IT WAS THE MEDIA THAT DID THAT.
SO YOU ARE GETTING THE MEDIA
THAT THEY LOVE TO TALK ABOUT
THEMSELVES, I AM A MEMBER OF THE
MEDIA AND I LOVE TO TALK ABOUT
MYSELF TOO, BUT THEY ARE THE
ONES GROWING UP.
SO THEY HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT
HOW MUCH THEY SCREW UP AND IT'S
FUN TO WATCH.
THEY ARE NOT JUST SAYING WE MADE
A MISTAKE, THEY ARE SAYING WE
DELIBERATELY MADE A MISTAKE.
WE DID NOT BELIEVE OUR OWN HEAD,
WE DO NOT BELIEVE REPUBLICANS,
WE ARE BIASED AND LAZY.
AND THEY ARE ADMITTING THAT THEY
DID NOT FOLLOW UP ON THE THEORY
BECAUSE OF POLITICS.
AND WHAT INDUSTRY DO YOU JUST
CELL PHONE YOURSELF LIKE THAT
AND SAY THAT YOU ARE BAD AT YOUR
JOB AND THINK YOU NEED A PAT ON
THE BACK BY ADMITTING YOU
SCREWED UP?
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO SELF
OBSESSED THAT THEY THINK THEY
ARE DOING THE HONORABLE THING BY
ADMITTING THEY MADE A MISTAKE.
>> Harlod: DO YOU AGREE?
>> Sandra: I THINK THE
QUESTION NOW IS HOW DOES THE
MEDIA HANDLED A COVER-UP THAT IT
CONTINUES TO ENGAGE IN NOT
PROVIDING EVIDENCE OR
CONCLUSIONS FROM THE LAB SAYING
THAT CHINA STILL REALLY NEEDS TO
PAY.
HOW MANY JOURNALISTS LEARN FROM
THEIR MISTAKE IN NOT SHUT DOWN
ANY IDEA THAT COMES FROM
DONALD TRUMP, MIKE POMPEO, AND
OTHERS AND ASK THE QUESTIONS.
IF YOU BRING YOURSELF BACK TO
THOSE DARK DAYS WHEN WE WERE
STARTING TO HEAR ABOUT THESE
SORT OF IDEAS AND THE THEORY
ABOUT THE WUHAN LAB, IT WAS
WORRISOME TO SEE THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA NOT DIGGING IN, NOT ASKING
THE QUESTIONS, NOT EVEN
CONSIDERING THAT TO BE A CASE,
AND I'M NOT SAYING EVERYONE, BUT
MANY IN THE MEDIA.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
THAT IS THEIR JOB.
>> Harlod: DAGEN, DO THEY GET
CREDIT FOR SAYING WE MADE A
MISTAKE, WE SHOULD HAVE DONE
THAT DIFFERENTLY?
>> Dagen: THEY DID NOT SAY
THAT THEY MADE A MISTAKE, THEY
ARE SAYING THAT IT WAS TRUMP'S
FAULT, THAT IT WAS AN IDEA
FLOATED BY MIKE POMPEO, NO, IT
WAS A REASONABLE THING TO
QUESTION AND IT WAS TOM COTTON
IN LATE JANUARY LAST YEAR, OH,
AND THEN THERE WAS OF SOUTH
CHINA UNIVERSITY TECHNOLOGY WHO
POSTED A PAPER ABOUT THE VIRUS
ORIGINATING POSSIBLY FROM A LAB
IN WUHAN, FROM THE LAB IN WUHAN,
OF COURSE THAT PAPER WAS TAKEN
DOWN.
BUT THEY WERE SO ANTI-TRUMP THAT
THEY WERE ANTISCIENCE,
ANTI-REASON, ANTILOGIC, AND ARE
PERFECTLY HAPPY WITH THAT
BECAUSE IF THEY HAD TALKED ABOUT
TODAY SLAB LEAK THEORY LAST
YEAR, TRUMP MIGHT HAVE ONE AND
STILL BEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
THAT HAS BEEN THE GOAL ALL ALONG
IS IT WAS PURELY POLITICAL, THEY
STILL CAN'T OWN THEIR MISTAKE.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE MALICIOUS
MAKEUP WEARING SMUG MONSTERS WHO
SPOTTED CHINESE COMMUNIST
PROPAGANDA FOR THE PAST YEAR.
>> Harlod: LET'S ASSUME THAT
THE CHINESE, THIS LAB IS WHERE
THE LEAK CAME FROM, WHAT DO WE
DO GOING FROM HERE?
WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
>> Greg: THIS IS AN
INTERESTING PROBLEM, BECAUSE I
THINK THAT CHINESE HAVE US OVER
A BARREL OF WET MATS, BECAUSE
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS SHOW THAT
WE HAD ANY BIT OF FUNDING DURING
THIS, THE UNITED STATES HELPED
FUND THIS THING, HOW WILL THEY
SUE THEM?
WE WILL HAVE TO SUE OURSELVES
COME BECAUSE I KIND OF THINGS
THAT WE HAD SOME FUNDING.
I KEEP HEARING THE STORY ABOUT
HOW THEY WAVED TO THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT ALLOWED THE
FUNDING TO CONTINUE.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
PROBABLY WHY NOTHING IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, BECAUSE WE MIGHT'VE OUR
FINGERS ALL OVER THOSE BATS.
BUT I LIKE THE SELF-REFLECTION
AND I AGREE WITH DAGEN THAT THEY
ARE ONLY SELF-REFLECTION BECAUSE
THERE IS NO RISK OF DANGER
INVOLVED, TRUMP ALREADY LOST.
BUT I THINK THE WEIRD THING
ABOUT THE MEDIA IS THAT IT IS
NOT SINGULARLY WRONG, THEY ARE
DOUBLY WRONG.
THEY CHOOSE THE WRONG IDEA AND
THEN WHEN THEY AVOID THE RIGHT
IDEA AND THEN THEY CHOOSE THE
WRONG IDEA, SO THEY ARE DOUBLY
WRONG TO SAY, THIS DID NOT WORK,
BUT WE REALLY LOVE ANDREW CUOMO
AND WHAT HE HAS BEEN DOING IN
NEW YORK.
IT'S LIKE NO, NO, NO.
IF YOU LOOK AT EVERY FACET OF
LIFE AND HOW THE MEDIA IMPACTS
IT, IT IS NEVER GOOD WEATHER IT
IS COVID OR CRIME OR RACE OR
PRO-LIFE MATTERS, WHATEVER IT
IS, THEY ADDED A VENEER THAT
MAKES IT FAR MORE DAMAGING THAN
IT HAS TO BE AND CREATES
UNNECESSARY PAIN AND SUFFERING
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND IMAGINE A SURGEON DECIDED
NOT TO USE AND EFFECTIVE THERAPY
ON YOUR KID BECAUSE HE WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH THE SCIENTISTS AND
THEY DID NOT GET ALONG?
THAT'S THE MEDIA.
>> Jesse: IF YOU ARE SAYING WE
GOT RID OF ALL OF THE MEDIA
EXCEPT FOR A FOX, WE WOULD HAVE
A BETTER COUNTRY?
>> Greg: LEGACY MEDIA.
TO THAT POINT, WE DON'T MIND
BEING WRONG, THIS WAS ALL BASED
ON AN IDEA THAT THEY COULD NOT
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT THE OTHER
SIDE COULD BE RIGHT.
THEY CAN ACCEPT THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS RIGHT, OR
TOM COTTON.
>> Jesse: HE GOES BY TOM.
>> Dagen: THEY ATTACKED PEOPLE
WHO BROUG